street hockey in front of the supreme
court of canada
dancing santa a couple of anti-semitic
signs
and horn blasts all day long
many who call ottawa home and don't live
in the middle of the road have had
enough these people are
taking our freedom away to promote their
own brand of freedom and i don't think
that's fair get rid of them
do you hear it down there that's where i
live
frustrated police won't move in to get
protesters out what i'm seeing is the
blatant hypocrisy in the way that
they're treating a largely white
demonstration versus a black and
indigenous organization i am sorry for
the living hell that you are enduring
during an update from police counselors
across the city expressed concern police
said the situation is now somewhere
between a demonstration and a long-term
effort to occupy the streets all options
are being discussed including military
aid but no specific plan put forward all
such options come with significant risks
risks to rioting
risk to injury and risk to death three
people have been arrested and charged
and police say multiple investigations
are ongoing with more protesters
expected to join this weekend the police
chief wouldn't answer how long this
could last
there may not be a policing solution to
this demonstration he says there is a
significant american component to the
protest and its significant funding the
gofundme campaign has surpassed 10
million dollars
late wednesday it was paused a message
reads it's under review to ensure it
complies with applicable laws i don't
know how long this is going to last but
try
two years of
losing your job not knowing if you're
going to lose your home 2023 2024 i'm
here for the rate i can't work
i can't work i can't go stateside
police pegged the costs of all this at
three million dollars and growing
compare that to the cost of the entire
canada 150 event on the hill it cost
less than half the price tag here
upwards of
thousand dollars a day and that doesn't
include the other impacts to the city
and the economy the rito center for
example a major downtown mall has said
it will stay closed until next week
donna
all right abigail beeman in ottawa
tonight thanks